we do genuinely get along none of us has
like had a freak out yet i'm realizing
it's only season two i don't even know
you guys
we should stir some [ __ ] up
hi i'm topher grace and i play tom
hayworth i am caitlin mcgee and i play
sarah hayworth i'm jimmy cajo i play
connor hayward i'm carla souza and i
play marina
i'm sushir zameda i play denise this is
the cast of home economics and we're
playing who's who sibling edition
[Music]
maybe tokyo
i want to say tokyo let's say topher
let's say toby yeah we're singing
it's not that i need to win is that i'm
going to win jump jump make it back i'll
make it you know that song
okay let's go
all right caitlyn
it's probably me yeah we gotta play a
group but
all right calm down i don't know yeah
i'm a [ __ ] angel
business call but this is a family
brunch and this is a business call
frank
i feel like maybe sushi babies yeah yeah
i love sleeping in and then i'll stay up
late
and then sleep late
because life is about balance yeah
[Music]
i feel like i'd call jimmy because i
feel like he would know a guy
i mean i feel like carla
is right or died harlow would help us
bury a body
[Laughter]
i think they've all heard the story
about me going to jail so that's when
you called carla and i called carla
carla i'm in tucson in an elf costume
gotta get me out of here
topher i think no no no no no caitlyn's
actually smart
oh whoa
i'm good
i'm good i would except for apparently
they changed math so what does that mean
people saying they changed yeah they
like changed my like it's a new math
what does that mean i don't know we'll
find out when i have kids like the way
they
you should like an idiot i look like an
idiot you're wearing a drink
[Music]
well my wife would hate to know this but
[Music]
it is who it is it's this side of the
room
yeah the side right
here yeah i mean should we start
drinking now that would really spice up
some wine right now
be sure to watch home economics this
wednesday september 22nd on abc
[Music]